were some frightening moments in the sky
after an apparent engine fire in a
Southwest Airlines flight out of Cuba
cell phone video taken inside the plane
shows the cabin filling up with smoke
and panicked passengers trying to secure
their oxygen masks Southwest Airlines
confirmed there were bird strikes on the
aircraft's nose and an engine the pilots
were forced to return to Havana and make
an emergency landing passengers were
seen evacuating the plane using
emergency slides on the runway the plane
was headed to Fort Lauderdale from
Havana the airline says no serious
injuries were reported and travelers
were rebooked on other flights